[Music]
you ever look through your wife's phone
no
[Laughter]
that was a brief pause there well i was
just thinking like why i don't have a
reason to so no i have not
uh all right well today we're looking at
couples looking through each other's
phones me neither by the way
is that an alienware computer oh [ __ ]
that probably runs so fast
do you look through your wife's phone no
but i know that some people have like
strict rules for their partner right
right that they have to show
that like text messages and [ __ ] like
that
what is this isn't like is it like a a
red flag sign tour like if you're
if your partner gets your phone and if
they see you freaking out or like if you
get their phone and they freak out it's
a bad sign right that's a natural
reaction ken okay
wait is it what do you got to hear that
i don't care who anyone touches my phone
i'm like
no give it back get it like that
why are you going through my photos oh
he got in there what do you got in there
no get off my that's normal all right
but
my point was more like when people
demand to be able to do it right
right right right i got you that's weird
that's suffocating you can't do that
it's also the same thing though like if
you don't so if you
okay ken give me your phone number here
here
yeah all right open up your uh
page okay my browser you want to see my
browser i
just want to look at your browser it's
uh
it's actually my social blade page there
you go
uh-huh okay well we know whenever
someone's acting jealous
that they're probably the ones that are
like if they say you're cheating felix
then they're probably the one cheating
that's what i was getting at sorry oh
that's hard to say it if you're cheating
then you start suspecting that maybe
they're doing it and they're keeping the
secret from you because you're keeping
it secret you you know you are
projecting like yourself onto that
let me see your phone give it to me are
you cheating because i am
yeah it's like when you play moga's and
you're the imposter and you
yeah and then you start believing
everyone else exactly it's better to
blame other people
oh i found her ex and i'm kissing
oh god why do you still have all these
photos
oh my gosh nice
i already know i'm going to love this
yeah
so then again what's your stance on x's
on your phone i mean
why would you keep that it depends on
how long they've been dating you know if
it's like a recent breakup and he's the
rebound and she has
good memories you know it depends
it all depends that's right man
that's weird though yeah that's weird
pretty weird that's weird
especially if you knew you're going on
the show and you left all your photos on
there it's kind of weird yeah
do they not know that i mean i i'd come
with a
factory uh
oh you want to look at my phone no
problem it's asking me to set it up
what all right
[Music]
what do we got
insecure it's the title of the show i'm
sasha
um and i'm danny and we've been dating
for a little over two months now
yeah okay two months that's not that
long yeah what a what a great title for
this show because they look like the
most insecure people ever they look very
insecure i didn't want to say it but i'm
glad you did yeah
they got the hunched over posture
fiddling with their hands
i mean the girl girl here she looks
pretty confident she knows she's gonna
find something juicy
but the tables will turn as we know them
what do you guys keep from each other
oh we got a nolan
he's hiding something notice that i
always scratched his head
look at him look at him sign him lying
right there
what are you hiding gramps what are you
hiding what kind of hentai do you watch
grapes
that good stuff so today you guys are
going to be going through each other's
phones
and laptops oh he looks scared dude
he's like what he's like today how do i
factor a reset what's the quickest way
to do it oh god
no they told me to bring this stuff but
i didn't think i'd be letting her go
with the show that granted i'm like oh
yeah
gotchas
i'm not too worried i have nothing to
hide we'll see about that
oh my gosh i feel like i wouldn't be as
worried at showing my partner as i would
be showing the internet
oh oh yeah
why did you lie for that why what are
you what are you what do you mean i was
like
hey mars are you cool with this he's
like yeah cool i'm cool with that then
the internet's like bro
well i'm not in control of what goes on
in the video that's more scary i don't
know
good luck people are weird all right
kane
what the [ __ ] is this oh they get to
watch each other okay okay i don't know
we've been married so long that
you know we're pretty open with each
other does she have any sexy photos of
you on there no
are you kidding i'm 62. that's a shame
yeah no more sex at 62. right he really
let himself go when he got to 61 you
know
nothing bad i think there is porn
what what
give this man an oscar right
i now believe it
[Laughter]
there is porn what
no i cleared my history oh my god also
he did
bro incognito mode hello
oh there's a picture of um his dick
what who takes dick pics i don't
understand it
no one wants to see anyone's day
unsolicited dick pics that's the only
way man
you got to save that special one you got
so you can send to everybody apparently
what this guy's doing i don't know
[ __ ] you ever you ever snapped the
photo down low
my wiener is nowhere on the internet
okay
[Laughter]
but you know
i remember one of the first phones i got
with a camera on it i was like
14 or some [ __ ] i'm like well where's
the sport check where's the story going
gotta do this gotta do it gotta snap
and then i remember i obviously deleted
right after
and i think this is why i'm so paranoid
with other people with my phone because
this girl has to look through my phone
for whatever [ __ ] reason
and the entire time i'm like did i
delete it did i delete it of course of
course i deleted it
but did i delete it i know it did i
actually did it and i kept going and
going and i'm like
give me my bug i ripped it out of her
hand and i was like
never doing that [ __ ] again it's my
fault
that was my first and last all right
after that i'm like no
so you have like a like a complex with
letting people look at your phone
because you're afraid they're going to
see your
ah your very old school wiener pick that
you
the school the phantom weiner that you
don't know if you delete or not
like on my old knock yes [ __ ] every
phone you got is like it's like it's
like a ghost haunting you
is that picture still there that deleted
it it could still be that who knows
it's hard it's hard to make jokes about
your 14 year old wien okay
well i appreciate it call it old school
i want to go to his instagram dms
okay there's a girl oh he's scared
he's sweating oh she left the keys
oh so he's hooking up with someone else
he messaged people on instagram
you didn't know that no oh
rip lonely ken huh jesus christ i
haven't used my instagram in so long
they took away my check mark you know
well they're ridiculous now you have to
like post a certain amount
yeah i'm screw that i don't care it's
the famous man there's one of her in her
bra
someone i used to hook up with he says
it's someone he used to hook up with
oh god joey post you
[Music]
[Laughter]
joey now we have to take one of me
i don't know who this is uh-oh figuroni
oh
that's my friend sh she says it's her
friend huh
you think you know someone figueroni
that's no way that's just a pal
no way pegaroni is
what are you doing oh just a
friend 60 years huh
oh she'd like the photo too
grandma's getting catfished grandma's
having catfish
oh no no no
yeah like [ __ ] i need to come up with a
name uh uh
i should ask marta if that's a really
telling name hey grandma
i i you know let's be friends like come
on
who is it okay i asked her we'll see if
she replies
okay i'll have her explain that when she
gets home does she have an idea
i don't know what that is she's laughing
she must have something to hide
nothing i don't have anything to hide oh
she's
twiddling with her hands what happened
to the trust he was like we got nothing
to hide
we're gonna have to talk about this
later then like found figeroni and he's
like oh well i guess there is something
going on here huh
if i find a figuroni and and my wife's
inside i mean we're gonna have to talk
i'm throwing up after drinking too much
and that makes me sad
i didn't know joey when he was drinking
i've only known him sober
so this is part of his personality that
i haven't seen does it scare you to see
his old self um yeah
if you had known him then would you be
with him now
whoa probably not what a question
damn she's very dramatic this is them
partying and having a great time but
someone took it too far and got sick and
now i just don't know if i can even
trust him anymore no no way how dare he
this is a whole lot of the personnel
this is dark evil side of him i never
knew he was like this
oh he's really big and deep oh my god
all right not to generalize women here i
think this is the old people thing in
general like that that's about the
journalism why did they never
marzia refuses to close her tabs
sorry martin's going to call you old
[Laughter]
does mary do this no she knows anytime i
use a computer it's like
i'm not a lie my instinct just goes
close all the tabs but if
it's a death sentence to even touch them
i just open a new one and hope the
computer doesn't explode
you should you should show mercy how to
use bookmarks i think
she could she's got them all open so she
can save the pages right they're
interesting things that she wants to go
back and look at yeah
man yeah yeah yeah yeah poor ram that
computer
is our central heating at this point
what is it shirtless tom cruise
okay sorry we're pausing so much but i
have to pause on
tom cruise for a very important reason
okay
is tom cruise handsome yes or no because
me and my sadder heated debate
and i will not say my opinion okay all
right is tom cruise handsome
i don't know if you hit me like you know
40 years ago
yeah pretty handsome yeah yeah
now he's he's still handsome but he's
definitely like
he's [ __ ] handsome mike
thinks it does not handsome at all the
older he gets the creepier he looks
you know she thinks bruce willis is the
most average looking dude on the planet
well i mean
he's the pinnacle of what an attractive
bald man looks like
you cannot say that he's not oh
[Laughter]
she thinks she looks like her uncle
everyone's uncle everyone's uncle
oh my god i can't believe this
oh man if tom cruise and bruce willis
isn't handsome then what am i
tom cruise is handsome the only thing
with tom cruise is he he's
start he's getting to the age to where
he looks like like he's still
he's still trying to look young is kind
of what it looks like now
which gets a little weird but anyway
bruce willis is definitely like default
character whenever you make it
shut i will not listen to this slam
there bruce willis [ __ ] you
i see some from his ex
how dare you save from your ex oh my god
these are really long messages
oh my god oh psycho warning who writes
that in the long messages
i don't think i've ever in my life
written that long message i don't think
i've ever read a message that long
no you get a message like that it's like
okay it's over i guess yeah you invite
them to play yeah
exactly what's the point what's the
[ __ ] point
there's only one response and that's the
invite to play eight ball
listen we can there's an easy way to
solve this
we gotta play
she says i'm tired of every single guy
talk to you're suspicious of
because she cheated on me why wouldn't i
it ended with her saying
sorry for texting this but it doesn't
look like we're going to talk anytime
soon
i've been saying i felt distant i want
to talk to you
you haven't done [ __ ]
my heart this hurts to read
all right go ahead and collect his
things
so that was it okay oh okay
all right let's see that was not too bad
you're not gonna fight see what graham's
hand oh wait wait
i just noticed his shirt as well it get
great because
the man the myth the grandpa did marty
tell you what the name if name was
a real name or not no it's not a real
name
so this this is gonna be juicy ah let's
see
let's start with the email oh she's not
gonna find anything
hmm this is very interesting ralph it's
a lot of sex toys
sex toys i don't know he needs
he it got him damn
she's really saying a lot about herself
here i don't know like that he needs
toys and she's like
thirsting over all these all over tom
cruise and
and macaroni whatever his name was
thirsty man that's a catfish name
macaroni i can't say no to him she's
such a
good little catholic girl i doubt i'd
find anything on her um
i found her porn
god okay i'm going straight to her
photos i know she has thousands
14 000 photos damn
bruh he's looking for the wiener right
now
oh if he has 1 400 photos he found that
pretty quick not gonna lie
yeah i found her ex and i'm kissing
oh god why do you still have all these
photos
oh my gosh him in his underwear
oh it wasn't even that big of a deal
yeah they might look like it's gonna be
so dramatic and she's like okay well
okay uh we'll see ex-boyfriend
he said you're freaking hot
i'm a demon picture of my face
that's cool that's a baller move right
there
i respect that hey [ __ ] got your [ __ ]
sorry i see you when you're translating
these dm's
[Laughter]
are there sexy photos he's liking yeah
oh what bruh bruh
someone needs to show grandpa how to use
instagram because there's way better
fillers than that on instagram
gramps come on you gotta use these
hashtags what are you doing what are you
doing man
you can find macaroni in there like come
on you're missing the good
give me a break
[Music]
he looks like he's hurting he's feeling
quite insecure right now
yeah it's almost like that's the name of
the chef
a lot of videos do people just expect
when they meet a new person that they
have no pass whatsoever and
[Music]
but i'm the most important person in
your life right
well you've met other people before me
delete your entire exist your existence
began when you met me all right
you understand this yeah well i do feel
it's fair though like if you
if you're dating somebody new and it
becomes like a real relationship
like longer than two months all right
you're gonna have to clear there yeah
you're gonna
have to get ready you gotta clean up
yeah because you don't hurt you gotta
take their feelings into consideration
at that point it's not so much about
your memories
you don't need pictures of that a's
while you're dating somebody else
innovative options for driveways
[Laughter]
that's my grams right there
and look only seven are eleven tabs open
wow ken open your browser right now i
don't know okay
i don't need to know my browser i have
one two three four five
six oh 35 ew
close them all what the [ __ ] wait
what's the margin it's almost my workout
routine i always forget it and i have to
look it up it's literally
the same thing over and over okay guys
you got you
30 wow oh it's down to one now don't
worry about it
did you only have one that wasn't your
workout routine you closed them all
[Laughter]
well felix i got a real question how
many tabs on your computer do you have
open right now
one just one yeah okay
well i have a tab that's just youtube
video ideas that i always like i'll
group them together
so on oh oh
what you don't even organize your
bookmarks either
i want her up there oh no
you felt you foul beans no
they're all they're all youtube ideas i
gotta need them all right
do you see my inbox google docs new dime
come on look at that video look at that
again
i got my inbox on there i got my youtube
and twitch and
nah nah nah nah you didn't even rename
that
would you rename it you're phil yeah
i'll be a slow you can do that
oh my god get out of here oh my god you
can't edit it
oh what if we oh start going backwards
let's see they didn't find anything so
they're planting
how dare you yes halle berry
she's new oh look at him oh [ __ ]
how do they know what else have you been
hiding
that's right why did he not say anything
what he's like i thought i closed all
those tabs
he's like oh
[Laughter]
how do you feel about her holding on to
texts and photos from her ex i don't
understand it personally because i go
back and like look at stuff if it's
there
i like purge like everything about the
relationship like as soon as possible
okay oh i found that one booty shirt
yeah yeah liar smile
ew i don't why is somebody put on a
shirt dude
does she talk about her ex a lot uh no
not at all actually
did you love him
he's asking him did you love his ex
that's such a such a weird thing anyway
did you did you laugh
did you love you love your ex yeah
obviously why else would you be in what
at the time yeah i mean to be fair she
just seems like the kind of person that
doesn't get rid of anything so that
she's probably got like three or four
x's in there
she probably has like 600 tabs on her
computer
and now they fight or what's gonna
happen okay
how was that for you guys stressful
so uh why do you keep all those photos
of your ex
oh yes yes yes yes
yeah why why why you got bad memory or
something
a lot of them are just good memories
that i really just don't want to delete
to be honest then why are you stay with
your ex then
i'd feel weird yeah i guess it depends
on how the relationship ended but then
again they haven't dated that
long so it's like i don't know two
months it's not that long
yeah it's still like i don't know what
they call that what the honeymoon phase
how long does that last when you're
dating someone
i thought it was just a month is it just
a month yeah but it also depends on how
like
i don't know how it ended with the that
x like if it was
if they had a terrible breakup i'm sure
she wouldn't believe everything right
but like a mutual like hey you know we
care about each other but it's just not
going to work yeah right
right right right right you had a porn
video in there in halibury in the nude
how dare she accuse him of that
what the hell is wrong with you all
right grime set up for yourself
that was the video
god he looks at concrete and nothing
else
a real man yeah a real name loves his
concrete
i'm glad that it's still logged in so we
can go through it together later yeah
that's true
can some things be private between you
yeah yeah
i'd say so mm-hmm i mean we just it's
probably healthy to have things that are
private
yeah it's just i there's a i feel like
there's a difference between like
privacy and secrecy
he has such a feminine voice yeah but
he's thinking it's harder that speaks
you guys have small hands too
do you notice that
yeah you're right they're smaller than
ours oh no brother
no no
you know what they say about small hands
small gloves
tiny i got i got hands
you got hands i got hands i got two two
of them i got small hands too i guess
just because you have a big truck or a
car does not mean anything
okay you're just throwing away ideas
there
because [ __ ] you moving on you guys love
each other
yes yes so that guy did say something
well he said that i think there's a
difference between secrecy and privacy
you know keeping secrets just keeping
private i think that's important all
right but yeah like if you keep it
secret
then you know that can be an issue but
if it's just i don't know there's
there's things that
matter to you that could hurt someone
else's feelings like you're like your
significant other kind of like the old
boyfriend pictures and the
girls own right right that'd be like
more of a private thing it's not so much
a secret thing i don't think let's just
keep it a secret that's a problem right
no
that's a good point actually it's like
uh i don't have any secret
like messages or anything but i also
feel like i i'd feel weird if someone
else had to go
through them yeah it's so private right
yeah yeah
that was so cringe ken
what's that mean with the old man's like
having a heart attack
oh cringe god
his face with the hell and berry there's
some
[Laughter]
older woman google searching shirt
that's the difference between privacy
and secrecy
yeah there you go yeah well we've
learned so much today thank you for
watching
check out ken yeah only 12 subscribe
and i'll see you guys tomorrow bye bye